imagina que estás viajando por algún
tipo de tierra extraña y fantástica y tu
misión es llegar hasta el castillo para
salvar a la princesa o al príncipe según
lo que tú quieras salvar pero para
llegar allá tienes que cruzar este río y
el problema es que no puedes cruzar
nadando porque es un río muy caudaloso y
muy agresivo así que tienes que cruzar
por este puente pero mientras te vas
acercando a este puente vez que hay un
gnomo
y ahí está el gnomo y dice yo soy un
gnomo muy racional así que para pasar el
puente necesitas pagar cinco pesos y es
justo cuando ves con más detalle que al
lado de él existe un letrero que de
hecho dice por pasar el puente necesitas
pagar cinco pesos bueno
desafortunadamente para ti tú no tienes
nada de dinero en los bolsillos y el
gnomo dice pues entonces no puedes
cruzar pero tú le réplicas oye gnomo es
que realmente esto cruzar es muy
importante y urgente que crucen entonces
el gnomo se tiente el corazón y te dice
mira te voy a dar una oportunidad para
que tú puedas pasar tendrás que
contestar un acertijo un acertijo
y acertijos este y hazlo como si fuera
el gnomo mira yo soy un humo muy rico
pues les cobró 5 pesos a cada persona
que pasa por el puente de hecho sólo
aceptó monedas de 5 o de 10 pesos obvio
que me dan 10 pesos entonces 2 de cambio
5 pesos además no acepto tarjeta de
crédito ni vales de despensa ni billetes
falsos ni hago trueques ni tiempo-aire
nada solamente efectivo y bueno no es
que te presume pero está ahorita he
ahorrado novecientas monedas
tengo un total de 900 monedas entre
monedas de 5 y de 10 pesos y bueno nada
más porque me caíste bien te voy a dar
otro dato como información si tú sumas
todo lo que tengo de dinero todo mi
dinero es decir si sumas todo el dinero
que tengo en las monedas de 5 y 10 pesos
entonces verás que tengo cinco mil
quinientos pesos así que vamos a apuntar
lo la cantidad de dinero que se junta
con todas las monedas de cinco y diez
pesos es de cinco mil quinientos pesos
nos resultó un gnomo bastante ahorrador
tiene ya cinco mil quinientos pesos
entonces el acertijo es que me des
exactamente y en 10 minutos y ojo digo
exactamente porque si te equivocas te
aventar el río y entonces algo terrible
te pasará a ti exactamente cuántas
monedas de 5 pesos y cuántas monedas de
10 pesos tengo cuántas monedas de 5
pesos y cuántas monedas de 10 pesos
tengo y ojo hablo como si fuera el
nombre y entonces tú te preguntas el
problema será consistente tiene solución
y esta solución será única pues si no
tiene solución seguramente te vas a ver
en muy poco tiempo atrapado por el río y
el nombre te va a decir si el problema
tiene solución única así que vamos a
resolverlo y me parece que resuelves los
hebraica mente es una buena forma de
hacerlo así que lo primero que sería
bueno que hiciéramos es definir
variables y si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos dos variables muy importantes de
hecho las dos variables que te preguntan
la cantidad de monedas de cinco pesos
que tienes y la cantidad de monedas de
diez pesos que tienes
así que definamos voy a decir que efe va
a ser el número de moneda
que tengo de 5 pesos el número la
cantidad de monedas que tengo de 5 pesos
y voy a decir qué tema que es el número
o la cantidad de monedas que tengo de 10
pesos así que ya definir efe es el
número de monedas que tengo de 5 pesos
del número de monedas que tengo de 10
pesos ahora me voy a fijar en el primer
renglón o en el primer dato que me dan
tengo un total de 900 monedas entre
monedas de 5 y de 10 pesos entonces
puedo escribir esta oración que tengo
aquí en forma algebraica es decir con
estas nuevas variables que acabo de
definir y la respuesta es que sí porque
fíjate si nosotros vemos la cantidad de
monedas que tenemos de cinco pesos pues
esos efe y si después nos fijamos en la
cantidad de monedas que tenemos de diez
pesos pues esos temas y si sumamos efe
master pues ésta es la cantidad de
monedas que tenemos en total la cantidad
de maderas que tenemos de cinco más la
cantidad de monedas que tenemos de diez
pues es igual a la cantidad de nuevas
que tenemos en total que son 900 monedas
por lo tanto efe
es igual a 900 y esta es la
representación algebraica del primer
dato que nos dan ahora vamos a ver si
podemos escribir el segundo dato que nos
dan de la misma manera y dice la
cantidad de dinero que tengo en monedas
de 5 y 10 pesos es de 5500 la cantidad
de dinero que se junta con las monedas
de 5 y de 10 pesos es de 5500 y para
escribir esto de una manera matemática
lo primero que me quiero fijar es en la
cantidad de dinero que tengo en el
número de monedas de 5 pesos y después
en la cantidad de dinero que tengo en el
número de monedas que tengo es de 10
pesos así que fíjate bien si yo
multiplico 5 veces el número de monedas
que tengo de 5 pesos porque su valor es
5 pesos entonces estoy sacando la
cantidad de dinero que tengo en las
monedas de 5 pesos porque por ejemplo si
yo tengo una moneda de 5 pesos pues
entonces tengo 5 pesos si tengo dos
monedas de 5 pesos pues de 5 por 2 que
son 10 pesos y así por lo tanto 5 veces
efe es la cantidad de dinero que me dan
el número de monedas que tengo de 5
pesos y de igual manera para sacar
la cantidad de dinero que tengo en el
número de monedas de 10 pesos 10 t es la
cantidad de dinero que me va a dar mi
número de monedas que tengo de 10 pesos
y ahora bien si yo sumo 5 efe más de
este pues es como sumar la cantidad de
dinero que tengo en las monedas de 5
pesos más la cantidad de dinero que
tengo en las más de 10 pesos lo cual me
da la cantidad de dinero que tengo que
son 5 mil 500 pesos es justo el segundo
dato que me dan la cantidad de dinero
que tengo en monedas de 5 y 10 pesos es
de 5 mil 500 pesos y entonces acabo de
escribir la segunda ecuación de una
manera matemática también y bueno ya
tengo dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
por lo tanto debo de tener una solución
y además una solución única porque
fíjate bien si yo me tomara solamente
una de estas dos ecuaciones tendría
bastantes combinaciones de poder obtener
el resultado podría combinar de varias
maneras la cantidad de monedas de diez
pesos la cantidad de monedas de cinco
pesos para que cumpliera una sola de
estas ecuaciones sin embargo en este
caso cuando tengo dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas me refiero a un sistema de
ecuaciones
estoy pensando que solamente existe un a
efe y un arte que satisfacen ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente y justo esa
es mi solución a esto se le conoce con
un sistema de ecuaciones debemos
escribirlo aquí y es justo lo que vamos
a ver y lo que vamos a resolver en los
siguientes vídeos